david police tell us this shooting
left one person dead and another one
hurt
here in the north valley this road is
still blocked off behind me as you can
see this investigation is ongoing
even though the shooting happened
several hours ago
we're told this all started just before
seven o'clock north las vegas police
came to a home here near
kerry and simmons in this neighborhood
after multiple calls
about a shooting when officers got here
they found one person with a gunshot
wound outside and a man
shot to death inside the house the first
victim was taken to umc
no word on a condition just yet on that
person
police are still investigating the
situation as i said they haven't
arrested a suspect just yet
but they do not believe this was random
they say there is no threat
to the public nothing like that to worry
about at this time
now again this is still an active
investigation so stay with 8 news now
for updates
i mentioned road being roads being
blocked in the area
these are mainly just neighborhood
residential roads no major thoroughfares
seem to be blocked off
as this crime scene continues to be
investigated so you should be
ok just avoid this maine neighborhood
area for now reporting live in the north
valley sasha loftis
8 news now sasha thank